need to start buying Christmas presents  and thinking what on earth are we gonna  do about Christmas Carrie Underwood is  already thinking about spending the  holidays with husband Mike and son  Isaiah you started singing dirty laundry  so it's really cute to hear him say you  know Jack this hard-working mom deserves  to kick back and indulge in some guilty  pleasures I mean I love a good glass of  red wine for sure yeah there are certain  TV programs I feel like I like to catch  up on her favorite show is by Walking  Dead and today she entertained military  families on the new Carnival Vista  cruise ship which makes its maiden  voyage in the US this week and after her  tour wraps Isaiah gets her all to  himself I'm just mom to him  you  you